this is the sit-down I'm your host
Patrick bid David in today's episode
we're gonna talk about one of my
favorite topics of all time and that's
the spirit of competition when my first
guests a good friend of mine Phil Heath
seven-time Olympia champion they call
him the gift he's got a complete
different style of competition than big
game James Worthy playing for the Lakers
Hall of Famer their enemy the Celtics
how did they treat the Celtics versus
Tony Hawk the greatest skate of all time
but he was very subtle completely
different than Chuck Liddell the Iceman
the man who knocked out so many people
he would put his hands out like this
people would go nuts he explains how he
competed in the UFC enjoy Phil Heath who
likes to be uncomfortable see I treat
life like a leg day who wants to train
arms of Phil Heath people lined up
around the corner chest to you lines
around the corner legs I don't know man
to tomorrow may have five people out of
100 because they know it's gonna be
painful they this is unexpected
it's the most uncomfortable situation
you're gonna be in as an athlete you
realize like this is a game so like you
said Ted Williams Usain Bolt's all those
guys they when they would hear trash
talk and this and then they're like okay
alright now let's go do it
do you intentionally create it because
they're you topside everybody knows you
are so do you also kind of do it to get
the other guys well there's two reasons
well there's multiple reasons right
number one you're trying to sell
I don't did this Phil he's getting a
portion of the ticket says no but let's
be real what people are so-called tired
of a champ being a champ this and that I
don't want you in hiding talking this
trash I want you to say it to my face
but you won't say it to my face because
you know my mentality you know that I'm
gonna absorb that I'm gonna embrace that
and I'm gonna use that fuel better than
they do
you obviously are not time acai green up
I mean you're now the heat you bring
nothing for him I mean he and I had a
great moment he chose to choose
different pastures hey fun things I
always have to come on in move
the other guys personally I think there
is respect and here's my thing I would
tell a lot of them get my cell phone
number you could text me and be like hey
Phil love you dude you're the big bro
you're you're the key but I'm coming to
kick your ass man who has said that you
who has that vo that's that is Owens so
then here's a question for you do you
think it helps to know that there's not
a definite number - that can really
compete with you today do you think
that's good for the sport I'm just gonna
be real what they should do this is what
the athletes ship dude second place has
been shifted from vegetation Shawn
Rhoden - yeah so what they should do
those guys who start talking to each
other they should be saying that's the
word the robbery is there's some inner
robberies within every league it doesn't
always have to be the top team and the
second-place team it could be other
teams or other individuals if you're
always trying to come after me why not
make it a three-headed monster coming
after Phil Heath the top five this is
net it explained you would tell them to
team up and you know try to compete
against each other so strengthen each
other then somebody can cook me anyway
they're trying to be - realistically can
anybody beat you
I guess realistically yeah I mean I can
get injured god forbid - you don't -
that he'll you take care of yourself
pretty good we've had some incredible
champions hany eight times Ronnie
eight times Arnold 7u7 you're about to
do eight it's Arnold working with you as
a flag carrier like bringing you up to
be the next face of them there's not a
you guys won't have that kind of a
relationship unfortunately we don't I
would love to have that and I think you
would love to have a because I think I
think it's important because you need to
be able to have someone to pass the
torsion unfortunately in this industry I
mean we're all very busy and I'll give
Arnold that you know he's very truly
busy man
I'll be seeing him next weekend you know
it is classic if I were to have five
minutes with them and literally look at
me the eye and tell him say look what is
it gonna take I think one thing you guys
could easily have that conversant when
was bodybuilding very popular we can say
when the harness horse Nagar was doing
it right we could say that right after
our don't suppose many was doing it what
was our one will also do he was a part
of governor sport of health and fitness
council health and fitness guys like me
should be a part of that if you're mr.
Olympia you're not a part of the
governor's board of health and fitness
where you live or the President's
Council of health and fitness there's a
problem
because of the fact that guys like
Schwarzenegger understood lifti they
understood determination you telling me
that I couldn't go to schools around the
country and we store that President's
Council of health and fitness tests
they're gonna be like hell yeah they're
because this guy's gonna yeah let's do
this and I can show them I'm a
functional athlete as well like why why
isn't that happening